[Musique]
leur indique où il répète en ce moment
avec son groupe les chansons de son
nouvel album intitulé wascat mathis i
win ce qui signifie en attikameks cercle
de vie un album lumineux mais dans
lequel n'hésite pas à aborder des
questions difficiles a fait l'album que
j'ai fait sam en fait sauvé la vie cet
album là aussi c'est de mon côté
personnel et où donc dans nos
communautés en plus les deuils l'issue
céder tout ça m'a fait beaucoup et et
j'essaye d'aider moments comme ça aussi
avec la musique puis je suis née
paulette messagère si leur unique wii
propose son indie folk bien
d'aujourd'hui
elle se nourrit aussi de son héritage
attikameks
l'artiste originaire de wemotaci en
mauricie habite désormais à trois
rivières mais elle reste très attachée à
sa communauté d'origine
fo y aller un moment donné c'est
vraiment c'est des gens très
accueillants et quand il voit du monde
qui vient de l'extérieur puis ils font
des parois ou des chants traditionnels
équipe et c'est ça aussi qui m'a qui
m'ont inspiré à un maître un peu temps
de paroisse
et
elle est une des rares auteure
compositrice interprète a chanté en
attikameks mais elle espère en inspirer
d'autres
c'est surtout les jeunes filles et
femmes qui veulent faire ce domaine
notre secteur je me sens un peu tout
seul encore en ce moment en attendant
auteur compositeur interprète mais
j'encourage beaucoup beaucoup les
artistes féminines d'aller voter
avec ce deuxième album très abouti
l'oranie crise affirme sans aucun doute
comme un nom à retenir est une belle
voix qui va compter
[Musique]
si nabi alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal
mais ça y est